hello and welcome to Sophie Ridge on
Sunday now there's not much the home
office dance that isn't controversial
crime policing anti-social behavior and
of course immigration especially with a
net in crisis and Small Boat Crossings
in the headlines daily and you don't get
a much more devices figure than the
current Home Secretary loved by the
right of the conservative party despised
by many on the left well this morning
we're going to be talking to suela
bravman Parliament might be on a break
for Easter but there is definitely no
shortage of politics for us to discuss
this morning
so our guests would in just a moment
we're going to bring you that interview
with the Home Secretary Sue Ella
ratherman who should be magically is on
the screen but she wasn't there we'll
see her very soon don't worry for labor
we'll talk to the party Shadow leveling
up secretary Lisa nandy and we're going
to hear from one of the most recognized
faces from the Downing Street covered
briefing so you a few years ago the now
chief executive of the UK Health
Security Agency Dr Jenny Harris we'll
also have a really personal interview
with the employment Minister that's guy
Offerman and he's talking about his
family's experience of losing a child
after birth it was an incredibly moving
interview to do as well
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this morning with my interview with the
Home Secretary just a few moments ago I
spoke to swella bravaman I started by
asking about those delays at Dover
what's the latest update you give us on
this situation in Dover
well I know that many families will be
very concerned about some of the delays
that we've been seeing at Dover over the
last 24 48 Hours people trying to get
away for their Easter holidays I would
urge them to check their travel plans if
they're about to set off to Dover but
that the situation is improving there's
been a an acute level of pressure put on
the ferry companies and the coach
companies a 35 increase in bookings it's
obviously always a busy time of year but
the government's in close contact with
the Port Authorities and the local
resilience Forum to ensure that we start
getting people crossing the channel
quickly you talk about the increase in
people trying to make the journey but of
course it's a busy time of year and the
CEO of Dover Port has said the
difference of living in a post-brexit
environment means that every passport
news be checked do we need to after
brexit just get used to this happening
at busy periods no I don't think that's
fair to say this has been uh you know an
adverse effect of brexit think we've
seen we've had many years now since
leaving the European Union and there's
been on the whole very good operations
and processes the Border but what I
would say is acute times when there's a
lot of pressure uh crossing the channel
whether that's uh on the the tunnel or
ferries then I think that there's always
going to be a backup and I just urge
everybody to be a bit patient while the
ferry companies work their way through
the backlog and I this is one other
story I want to ask you about before we
get onto your announcement and three
British men being held by the Taliban
now one of them is Miles rootledge a
so-called danger tourist he returned to
Afghanistan after being previously
evacuated by armed forces from the UK
well anyone traveling to uh dangerous
parts of the world should take uh the
utmost caution if they are going to do
that they should always act on the
advice of the foreign office travel
advice that says this guy's been
violated before and I think you know if
there are risks to people's safety if
there are British citizen abroad then
the UK government is going to do
whatever it takes to ensure that they're
safe and the government is in
negotiations
um and working hard to ensure people uh
people safety is upheld so you are in
negotiation Center well we're always
well if there are problems and if there
are safety concerns uh to British
individuals who brought them the scdo
will be
working actively to ensure people are
safe I want to talk about your policy
it's about child sexual exploitation
just explain what it is that you're
announcing today
well there's been uh there's been
several reports over recent years about
what I consider to be one of the biggest
scandals actually in recent years in in
our history and that is a systematic and
institutional failure
to safeguard the welfare of children
when it comes to sexual abuse and we saw
recently Professor Jay's report be
published and that makes very harrowing
reading and what I'm announcing today
and the Prime Minister will be building
on this tomorrow is a series of measures
to bring an end to this and properly
Safeguard children it's a consultation
why why is that a consultation people
have been demanding action for years
what's important to remember is that
what we're seeing in grooming gangs or
gangs of rapists is in towns and cities
around the country we're seeing a
practice evolve which has evolved which
is taking advantage of vulnerable
children and let's be honest happening
you say it's a great Scandal why are you
Consulting why do you not just take
action well we need to get the legal
Duty right we don't want unintended
consequences but what's clear is that
what we've seen is a practice whereby uh
vulnerable White English girls
um sometimes in care sometimes who are
in challenging circumstances being
pursued and raped and drugged and harmed
by gangs of British Pakistani men who've
worked in child abuse Rings or networks
we've seen institutions and state
agencies whether it's social workers
teachers the police turn a blind eye to
these to these signs of abuse out of
political correctness out of fear of
being called racist out of fear of being
called bigoted and as a result thousands
we're not talking in small numbers we're
talking large number thousands of
children have had their childhoods
robbed and devastated and there are many
of these perpetrators still running wild
behaving in this way and it's now down
to the authorities to track these
perpetrators down without fear or favor
relentlessly and bring them to justice
you say that the premise is going to
build on this tomorrow what else are we
expecting well today I've announced that
we are going to introduce a consultation
on mandatory reporting what the reports
show is as I said professionals who had
duties on safeguarding and looking after
the welfare of children saw the signs
things were reported to them uh concerns
about abuse or rape or exportation were
disclosed to these professionals and
they didn't take any action it's
outrageous what we're looking at is
imposing a duty on anybody or a
professionals who are in working in
child safeguarding to actually report
and take action when they come into
possession of information that may raise
concern I think everyone is over the
last few years has been horrified by
some of the reports and as you say
um the fact that some of these girls
were simply not believed vulnerable
young people not being believed not
being taken seriously
um do you also accept those that
grooming gangs are not necessarily just
Pakistani so home office report in 2020
found grooming gangs most commonly white
and despite some of the high profile
cases that we described they said that
the links between ethnicity and this
form of offending could not be proven
well I refer you to the extensive report
uh about Rotherham several years back
followed by the report by Louise Casey
those two reports were unflinching in
their assessment of the problem there
have been several reports since about
the predominance of certain ethnic
groups and I say British Pakistani males
who hold cultural values totally at odds
with British values who see women in a
demeaned and illegitimate way and pursue
an outdated and frankly heinous approach
in terms of the way they behave we've
got to stamp that out with criminal law
and proper safeguarding and we're only
going to do that if as a society we face
up to the facts and the truth of what's
actually going on you talked there about
Lewis Casey and a big part of this as
well is trust in the Met right if you're
talking about child sexual abuse in any
sort of sexual abuse as well now the
case review internet police said it was
institutionally racist and misogynistic
is it fit for purpose and your Home
Secretary right what are you going to do
about it
well I've spoken at length about uh the
challenges with the met and no one's
shying away from the big challenges that
the Met faces right now we're saying no
one's showing away from it the Met
Police Commissioner Rob Rowley has
refused to use the word institutionally
racist do you think he is actually not
really getting to grips with the
seriousness of what's happening I
disagree with that Sir Mark Rowley and
Dave Lynn Owens are the right people to
lead the Met now and Louise Casey
accepts that as well in her report also
Louise says that the vast majority of
serving police officers in the Met are
decent Law Abiding and uphold the
highest standard that's true but at the
same time we've had serving met police
officers raping and murdering women
taking selfies with dead bodies joking
about domestic violence and race making
racist comments I mean it is actually
incredible to see are you prepared to
break up the net if things don't improve
all of that is totally unacceptable and
the findings that Louise Casey makes of
the instances of misogyny racism
homophobia are all totally unacceptable
if it doesn't improve well even Louise
Casey doesn't recommend breaking up the
mess so I'm personally not uh at that
point I think what we've got to do is
raise standards of vetting and
recruitment I'm Consulting on the
dismissals power what we found is Chief
constables lack sufficient powers to
actually get rid of poor performing
officers uh absurdly and I'm if we need
to change the law I will do that but
ultimately we've got to ensure that the
Met commissioner sticks to his
turnaround plan and is held to account
by by the mayor of London in fact it's
important what happens an important
element here is the governance now the
PCC in this case the labor mayor of
London has a lot to answer for because
he's responsible ultimately for
performance and outcomes by the Met
um now I want to talk to you about
immigration as well because in October
when you were talking about your policy
to deport migrants to Rwanda you said in
a speech at the Tory Party Conference I
would love to have a front page of the
telegraph with a plane taking off to
Rwanda that's my dream it's my obsession
do you think that sounds a bit
a bit weird I guess is the phrase I'm
looking at that it's your dream it's
your obsession to see a plane take your
time listen I make no apology I care
very passionately about uh stopping the
boats just like the Prime Minister does
just like the vast majority of British
people do this is a problem of 45 000
people last year who arrived here
illegally uh without a legal basis
without permission abusing the
generosity of the British people we're
spending over six million pounds a night
on Hotel accommodation with three
billion pounds last year this cannot go
on so we can quibble about semantics but
the reality is what action are we taking
okay let's stop let's talk about action
then so will flights to Rwanda take off
by the summer
listen I uh we are making very steady
progress will they take off I'm not
going to give a deadline as to when
flights will take off uh we have to be
realistic we've had a very strong
victory in the high court at the end of
last year on Rwanda we've now introduced
legislation we want to move as quickly
as possible to relocate people from the
UK to Rwanda the sun on Sunday is
reporting you're set to announce a deal
with a Port Authority at Portland and
door set to Docker floating ship housing
migrants Etc
well as my as we announced earlier this
week we have uh we're going to be moving
forward with uh procuring is that true
that the deal in Portland I'm not going
to talk about private commercial
transactions in that negotiation in that
case right you can't tell me when the
flight's going to take off to Rwanda and
we've got no information about about um
whether or not these ships are going to
be actually used or any information so
if you don't mind I might not talk in
depth about Rwanda all the ships because
so far since a policy was announced
we've had zero flights taking up to
Rwanda we've got zero announcements on
the ships let's talk about things that
are actually happening now okay and we
can talk about these things when you've
successfully sent a single person to
Rwanda
let's have a look you mentioned the
small boats Graphics this is the number
of people arriving in the UK on small
boats you say that it's gone up and it
has 45
755. this is under a conservative
government and it's also partly
underused Home Secretary do you accept
that things are failing
I accept we've got an unsustainable
problem I've been very clear about that
I'm aware of the numbers
are failing the context is important
we're in the middle of a global
migration crisis the UK is not alone
with facing unprecedented numbers of
illegal arrivals you speak to the French
you speak to the U.S you speak to other
Western democracies they are all
grappling with unprecedented
responsibility of illegal migrant team
that's what I'm saying I mean if I could
talk finish a sentence and I might be
able to set out what we're actually
doing we're all de grappling with
unprecedented numbers of people we have
to take action now that's why we've
introduced a bill with tough measures
which are both firm and humanitarian
they will introduce a deterrent so that
people stop taking the journey in the
first place and important okay and we'll
talk evil people smuggling gangs are
stopped when they actually happen none
of this stuff has actually happened yet
despite the policy being announced in
April let's have a look at hotels Asylum
Seekers and temporary accommodation you
can see it's spiking there do you take
responsibility
this as Home Secretary well you want to
talk about things that have happened I
will show you some progress actually so
since December when the Prime Minister
made his announcement about our plan to
stop the boats we've struck a deal with
Albania we've now seen
um uh several hundred about 500 people
returned to Albania who came here
unlawfully we've also seen a record deal
with the French which has enhanced our
cooperation on the channel that's a
large part of the solution and we're now
about to procure and roll out bespoke
accommodation for Asylum Seekers so we
can start taking people out of hotels
and moving in them into more affordable
and appropriate accommodation so you
talked there about the successes
um and that as you say is partly because
of the returns agreement you struck with
albanians why aren't you talking about
things like return agreements rather
than talking about things like Rwanda
things like Hotel barges barges for
migrants that frankly you know I just I
forgive my skepticism but they're not
happening are they
well I mean I really disagree with your
assumption I mean we're announcing these
measures because we've been working
intensively over the last few months to
arrange
um agreements Provisions these are large
complex projects that we have to
deliver you can't just announce them and
they happen overnight and that's not the
real world the real world in the real
world and working government you have to
take things step by step you have to
overcome legal procedural planning
challenges we need to we have made
announcement a pretty pivotal and
landmark announcement this week about
several sites that we have identified
around the country which we believe are
appropriate for a housing accommodate
housing Asylum Seekers and we plan to
start moving Asylum Seekers into those
sites very soon if an asylum Seeker
enters the UK immediately illegally
sorry so if an asylum Seeker enters the
UK illegally and then admits that they
made a mistake should they allow be
allowed to come back six days later I
don't think
um that get paying a people Smuggler
thousands of pounds
risking your life in a flimsy dinghy
with a thin piece of polystyrene as a
life jacket traveling at 2AM at night in
freezing cold conditions is a mistake
and I think anyone who takes the journey
is breaking the law anyone who procures
that Journey offers it or facilitates it
is breaking the law anyone who does that
is making a deliberate decision to come
to the UK illegally you don't do that by
mistake and that's why we need a robust
legal framework to ensure that anyone
who does come from a safe country
remember they're coming from a safe
country where they could claim Asylum
there is no good reason as to why they
should be taking that treacherous
Journey with the people smuggling gangs
to come to the UK on a flimsy dinghy the
reason I ask the question is that you
resigned of course for committing a
national security breach for committing
a security breach and for breaking
ministerial rules then came back into
the same job six days later do you just
not think the rules apply to you
uh well to correct you I didn't commit a
national security breach I set out in
full the circumstances of an email that
I sent to a colleague about an issue
which was uh pretty much open government
policy there was no National Security
element so please do correct your your
statement on that what I'm saying is
here we need to ensure that there is a
firm and robust legal framework by
whereby if you arrive in the UK
illegally you'll be determining robust
framework around the minister you'll be
detailed you did commit a security
breach you'll be detained and thereafter
swiftly removed that's what the British
people want us to do they want us to
stop the boats we need a deterrent we
need people to stop making that journey
in the first place we need to stop
seeing 45
000 people arriving here illegally we
need to stop housing 45 000 people in
hotels around towns and cities in the UK
that's when we'll be able to stop those
and that's why the prime ministers made
it one of his five key pledges because
he knows the vast majority of British
people care passionately okay we'll look
at the figures uh in next time you're on
the program and see there's been an
improvement I just want to talk a bit
about you and what you stand for because
when you ran for the party leadership
you wrote an article in Express to
launch your campaign and you said we
need to deliver rapid and large tax cuts
how do you feel being part of a
government where taxes are due to you
know potentially reach their highest
levels since the Second World War
I'm a low tax conservative and I know
that the prime minister is as well and
everybody in the uh cabinet is going up
then well we've had unprecedented shocks
to our economy over recent years whether
that's the impacts of the pandemic uh uh
inflation caused by a global energy
Supply challenge because of the war in
Ukraine those have required flexibility
of your Economic Policy you're
comfortable with they aren't tax levels
wholeheartedly supportive of the
government's measured and balanced
approach we want to you come back to our
current but of course we need to get
public spending under control we need to
uh you need to get the debt down we need
to grow the economy and we need to halve
inflation those are parts of the prime
minister's plan okay now if I may you're
quite divisive figure I think that's
probably you know no sort of secret you
become the face of a government's policy
on migration that some people find you
know immeasurably cruel you obviously
believe in it
do you relish the five or is it taking a
bit of a personal toll on you
well I see my role as Home Secretary as
um getting results ultimately taking
action for the British people I see
myself as telling the truth for the
British people to the British people I
see myself as being a voice for the
law-abiding patriotic often silent
majority I see myself being heavily
informed by the people in my
constituency in pharah who just want us
to stop the boats although it is fair to
say labor currently six points ahead on
immigration who want us to see Common
Sense policing who want to keep the
British people safe that's my objective
as Home Secretary and you know if the
BBC or you know various celebrities are
offended then so be it you talk about
various celebrities and your husband did
an interview recently where he spoke out
about Gary lineker's tweet where he
compared the rhetoric around small boats
uh to that of 1930s Germany your husband
said that legitimized some of the abuse
that you've faced do you think it's
right that he's still presenting much
today
listen it's not for me to decide uh who
the programming schedule for the BBC uh
you know I I've spoken about the issue
uh with Gary lineker what I think is
important what I think the majority of
people really care about is the action
we're taking so the bill that we've
introduced will make clear that if you
arrive here illegally you'll be detained
and swiftly removed I'm very optimistic
about the passage of that bill we've
just had it go through several stages in
the Commons recently we're ongoing
without process we've just announced new
sites for accommodation Asylum Seekers
we're making progress on Amazon on our
Asylum backlog we've seen several
thousands of cases being made and
increase productivity that's an
important element of our plan we've
reached a record deal with France a
returns agreement with Albania I think
we're making tangible process in a short
period of time but ultimately yes you'll
judge us on our record
we're out of time thank you
swallow bravman uh right there saying
that she'll be judged on her record and
of course we'll keep across those
numbers to see any movement on them in
the meantime we can get the view from
labor now and speak to the party Shadow
leveling up secretary Lisa nandi who is
in Salford for us thank you very much
for being on the program today Lisa
um just firstly I started off with a
situation in Dover when I spoke to the
Home Secretary earlier and we've seen
those cues of course the CEO of the port
saying that one of the issues is that
post brexit you have to check everyone's
passport Sue Ella bravoman said that
actually I don't think it's fair to say
that this is an adverse effect of brexit
who's right
well actually I think the problem is
that we haven't had a government that
has planned for what was going to happen
post-brexit there are clearly a range of
factors that have gone into the delays
here and we've seen them before but the
government has known for a very long
time that they needed to make sure that
there were resources in place to deal
with additional paperwork checks the
point is not whether we left the
European Union or not the point was that
we left with a government that made big
promises and once again didn't deliver
and I really feel for the families that
are trying to get away for a Easter
break people who've been caught up in
this chaos people whose livelihoods are
threatened it didn't need to be this way
and if the government got a grip got
down to Brass tax and started doing
their actual job all these things could
be avoided
uh one of the other things that we spoke
about in the interview was the new
policy to try and consult on mandatory
reporting where people might have a fear
that child sexual exploitation is taking
place now within the interview the Home
Secretary said that she felt it was one
of the biggest scandals that we've seen
in her words vulnerable White English
girls being pursued and raped and
drugged and harmed by gangs of British
Pakistani men and that people have
turned a blind eye due to political
correctness
do you think she's right
well I think we're the Home Secretary
needs to get real we're failing young
people in this country online in on our
streets and in their homes because the
government is just simply not taking it
seriously 20 years ago I was working
with children who were being groomed by
criminal gangs for the children's
Society trying to help them Escape that
there were huge problems with the courts
at the time and them having to give
evidence in person there were there were
some delays in the court system that
made it difficult for them to get access
to Justice we'd call for mandatory
reporting for 20 years so that
professionals working with children and
young people knew that they were under a
duty to report on the behavior of not
just other people but of their own
colleagues if they suspected that there
was a problem and here we are after 13
years of Tory government and finally the
Home Secretary has just woken up and
said let's let's do something about it
and all we've got is a consultation that
is not the mark of a serious government
they must honestly think that we are
fools if they think that we're going to
fall for this as a sign that the
government is taking seriously what is a
huge Scandal and an absolute disgrace
for some of the most vulnerable young
people in this country I think everyone
would agree um about the scandal of
these young girls not being listened to
um appalling but is she right to talk
about the racial profile at some of
these gangs when obviously grooming
gangs sadly happen across all cultures
it's true that they do happen across all
cultures there were when I was working
with children and young people there
were particular issues with
um Kurdish and Pakistani gangs in some
parts of the country there are also huge
issues with white men grooming young
girls online and there are also problems
with boys as well let's not forget that
boys don't escape from these problems
it's just that often what happens is
that they go even more unreported and
unrecognized than girls I think the
problem with what the Home Secretary is
trying to do is that she's trying to
single out one particular profile and
one particular group and the risk is
that if you do that you miss the fact
that there is child abuse going on in
plain sight in homes on the streets and
online and we ought to surely be aiming
to keep all young people safe from the
harm that is created not just singling
out some young people and and
highlighting those forms of abuse and
discrimination they this is a government
that just hasn't taken that seriously
for 13 years so you'll excuse me if I'm
skeptical about Home Secretary who
suddenly pops up with a press release
just a few months away potentially from
a general election
few months away from a general election
do you know something that I don't well
I mean when whenever the general
election comes we'll be ready for it but
okay honestly I mean if you look at the
failure of this government to preside
over huge backlogs in the courts at the
moment she's talking about young people
being prevented from being harmed and
getting access to justice but the courts
have come to a standstill because people
can't get through them and they've
presided over chaos the online harms
bill has been dragging on through the
House of Commons with no sense of
urgency okay I would say to the Home
Secretary stop with the press releases
start rolling up your sleeves and doing
your actual job okay now labor is
calling on the government to freeze
council tax
um you are saying that you're going to
pay for it through a whimful tax it
feels a little bit like as if the
windfall tax is magically solving all of
Labor's problems at the minute when we
all know that of course the amount of
money the amount of Revenue you get from
a windfall tax fluctuates massively
depending on the price of oil and gas
which is already starting to level out
you can't rely on it can use a steady
stream of income to fix every possible
economic problem that's going to come
your way
no of course not but we calculate that
the windfall tax could raise around 10
billion pounds the cost of freezing
current prices this year would cost
but but but right now if you were to do
what we were asking the government to do
to cancel the investment allowances to
raise the level of the windfall tax and
to back date it to when we first called
for it you could raise about 10 billion
pounds now if you raised about 10
billion pounds you could easily use
about 2.92 billion of that to freeze
council tax this year I recognize that
this is not a long-term solution to the
problems that councils face to do that
we need wholesale transformation of the
way that councils and communities are
funded in this country but right now
people's food bills are going up the
housing bills are going up their energy
bills are going up and their taxes are
about to go up as well because the
government is asking councils to put up
council tax by five percent we think
that that is just wrong a time when
people are struggling and that we should
use some of the money from the profits
that big companies are making in order
to ease the pain for people this April
I just feel like I'm talking about the
windfall tax because I feel like every
interview we end up talking about the
windfall tax and I accept it's a popular
policy but it is just one policy that
was announced over a year ago what's the
biggest policy that labor has announced
since the wimple tax
well I mean we've announced for example
that we want 70 of
um of people to be able to realize their
Ambitions of home ownership we announced
that at a conference last year and
through a system of state-backed
mortgage insurance and Rachel Reeves and
I have been working with the big lenders
in order to make that a reality I think
you know policies like solving the
housing crisis introducing breakfast
clubs the housing crisis so is it that's
an ambition
it's an ambition that we intend to
deliver we'll set ourselves a Target in
government to do so and we'll deliver on
it we've said
um just earlier this month that we want
to achieve the highest sustained growth
in the G7 driven by people in all parts
of Britain and we're working across the
board with businesses and Council
leaders and investors in order to make
that a reality because we know in the
end that windfall tax a windfall tax
will be a fairer way of funding things
right now but none of this can
compensate for 13 years of low or no
growth in this country if you want
really good Public Services if you want
choices and chances for our kids in
every part of the country you've got to
get the economy growing and I make no
apology for saying that that's why labor
has made that absolutely Central to our
program for government
okay thank you very much uh indeed Lisa
nandy there for labor
are you watching City Ridge on uh Sunday
busy morning at say five of course
dominated by the interview with the
Holmes secretary and now as usual the
take is going to follow this program
just after 9 30 a chance to analyze
today's interviews and talk through some
news lines with our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates who I just want to
talk to now because we can get a quick
take from Sam who is there for us um
with the Home Secretary I was very keen
not to get dragged into the Rwanda
policy too much since that nothing has
happened on it for over a year and it
feels like it is you know a bit of red
meat I guess that they're Keen to talk
about what did you make about of the
interview
look I think that the government the top
of government know that they have a
problem and what was fascinating uh in
your interview with Zoella Brotherman is
that they cannot admit it in public
they've got a problem with small boats
and it's exactly the one that you honed
in on when talking to the Home Secretary
um essentially it's that they've made a
lot of announcements but they haven't
actually changed very much legislation
is still working its way through
Parliament to change things it's
entirely unclear when we're going to
actually get flights to Rwanda the legal
situation if the Strasbourg Court object
was not entirely clear what happens at
that point and whether the government
would just ignore the Court ruling or
press ahead all of that means we are
about as the weather gets a little bit
better to have another season where
people in government think they're going
to be even more boats coming across the
channel and people will see that footage
all summer so we're about to head into a
period where frankly it's going to look
like the government are failing because
they haven't actually done anything yet
they've just made announcements and I
think that that discrepancy they're not
preparing the public for and that's
going to be an issue yeah it certainly
is she said she'll be judged on the
record and that that well we'll keep
getting those graphs out thank you very
much uh Sam indeed we'll have more from
Sam later on but still to come on the
program in just a moment we are going to
be hearing from this lady probably
recognized her face from those covered
briefings she's the chief executive at
the house security agency Jenny Harris
and a little later on we're going to
have a really personal interview with
the employment minister in conservative
MP guy Offerman now he's talking about
his family's experience and baby loss
something I know affects so many and
[Music]
thank you
now it's really hard to forget those
dining Street briefings during the
covered pandemic when the whole country
seemed to stop and hang on to every word
you know the tragedy of how many people
had died what new restrictions they
could be on our lives and they made a
household name of many including this
woman
over time probably over the next six
months we will have a three-week review
we will see where we're going we need to
keep that lid on and then gradually we
will be able to hopefully adjust some of
the social distancing measures and
gradually get us all back to normal I
have to admit I stood here I think about
10 days ago and said uh very uh probably
optimistically now in the past we've
we've solved the PPE position so my
apologies because 48 hours later I think
our distribution issue had popped back
in again
well back then Dr Jenny Harris was the
deputy chief medical officer for England
as part of an extraordinary career in
public health she was also on the Joint
Committee for vaccination and
immunization and played Central roles in
the UK's response to Ebola zika Montague
pox MERS novichok attacks and of course
kovid while she's now chief executive of
the UK Health Security Agency and I
spoke to her a little earlier this week
thanks so much for being on the program
um two years on from setting up the UK
Health Security Agency can I ask the
obvious question first what does it
actually do uh well we're here to
protect lives to save livelihoods we
have a a remit to protect the population
against not just infectious disease but
other external Health threats so
chemical radiation environmental hazards
it's a new organization those things
always happened in the UK but there is a
particular focus on it now and we're
able I think more obviously to deploy
our scientific skills particularly I
mean you were set up in the middle of
covid it's been a bit of a journey I can
imagine
I think that's a fair description when
I'm talking to people and often they'll
ask me that question I say it's been a
very exciting time it's a bit like um an
exaggerated action learning set so uh
obviously we were put up as a new
organization in the middle of a pandemic
to fight pandemics and that's one of our
principal focuses but nevertheless
sitting at the back of this is a
considerable round of work that goes on
routinely that I think many of the
public are not aware of so routines
events of huge numbers of infectious
diseases as well as operational
capability to respond to health threats
for example just recently you've seen
the the Dorset leakage for example that
was a South West Health Protection Team
sorting cooperating with blue light
services on oil leakage in a harbor so a
whole host of things ongoing all the
time if you're talking about kind of
upcoming threats and challenges is there
anything that you've got your eye on
that you're particularly worried about
we are reviewing this at the moment
because I think it's important as a new
agency that we have a very systematic
approach perhaps in a new way that the
country hasn't had there's always been a
national risk assessment ongoing
continuously but I think what we've seen
with covid is a new focus and
understanding of how severe and how
significant infectious disease
particularly can be not just in the UK
but globally as well to our lives but
also our livelihoods so both the health
and economic costs if we look back a few
months we knew about monkeypox mpox for
example it's not a new virus but the way
that it has spread recently in terms of
much wider transmission remains an
ongoing concern but then if we look
forward of course we're now talking
about Avian Influenza again not a new
risk we've known about but one where we
are starting to see some changes in
potentially a mammalian transmission not
yet in humans so with avian influence
something you're specifically looking at
just in case it does start to become a
restitution absolutely and if any of
your viewers want to look one of the key
aims of the organization is to be as
transparent as we possibly can with data
and with our knowledge and so one of the
things we've become quite famous for
possibly internationally more than in
the UK is our technical briefings how
much of a risk is it to humans so the
risk to humans at the moment has not
changed and that's what you'll you'll
see there but what we are starting to
look at is the change we obviously have
genomic sequencing now which gives us
much more insight into how viruses are
changing and we're starting to look at
changes a little small changes in
mammalian Transmissions so we've had for
example Spanish mink farms and and a few
seals but I think the general message to
people is this for human risk it hasn't
changed at all but it's definitely
something we're keeping an eye on now
because you're not spokesperson for the
NHS but Health Services always impact
each other it's it's it's they're not
independent if you like and I know a lot
of our viewers are worried about the
state of the NHS you've had a difficult
winter with strep a with flu with covid
of course and pressures on on doctors
and I just want to take the opportunity
as I've got someone who isn't a
politician in the chair and can give me
a bit more of a neutral response how
worried should we be about the state of
the National Health Service so you're
right I'm not a politician I am a doctor
and it gives me a great opportunity
actually to give a caller and thank you
to all my clinical colleagues working on
the front line right through covert but
as you've said particularly through
recent incidents
um I mean obviously the overall
strategic approach to NHS management is
very much for politicians I think what
we've seen over this winter though is
something which we could partially
predict but was difficult to understand
uh the detail overhead so you've
mentioned I guess so invasive group a
streptococcal disease what we've seen
with that is a different seasonality for
it and do you think that's because of
covert because of the law almost
certainly we've got high degrees of
uncertainty where infectious diseases
will overlap with each other so what
we're seeing this year is which we
didn't want but had planned for was flu
interacting exactly the same time as a
covered Peak so we have them together
we've had a group a strep coming earlier
and we've had RSV restrictions in Cydia
virus which we'd normally see earlier
coming a little bit later and how is the
health of the NHS itself because these
kind of challenges are going to come up
do you think it's in a good place
I'm not working directly on the front
line though so I think those questions
are much better asked of Representatives
directly I I do know that colleagues are
working super hard and I think the
important thing for me is getting shared
understanding of what we're expecting
using our data which we have done this
winter to help colleagues on the front
line and in management predict what
services might be impacting now it's
weird because for me it almost feels
like covert's a bit of a bad dream like
I can't really believe it actually
happened
um is that Fairview or am I actually
completely wrong and covert is still
actually a very real threat it's very
much here it's going to be a threat in
the same way that flu is a threat flu is
still at the top of our national risk
assessment in case it changes and we
have a flu pandemic so I wouldn't like
to think it had gone away but what we
have done and the living with covert
policy says is using vaccines
particularly but new treatments as well
we have largely got it under control at
the moment
um I think your approach to it was a bad
dream many people feel this as a natural
psychology that says when some large
event has happened and we've all worked
our way through it it's nice to forget
it I think it's my responsibility
leading the UK to say not to forget that
and make sure we learn lessons from it
identify those and put them into action
to talk about those lessons you
mentioned vaccines which many would say
that's the big success of academic
response what do you think was the
biggest mistake
um so there's a public inquiry ongoing
and we're contributing to that along
with everyone else we want to learn from
things that could have been done better
but I think there's a lot of retro
retrospector scoping ongoing at the
moment and that's quite dangerous what
we want is objective evidence of where
we can do things better going forward I
think what we're trying to take forward
is being more prepared about things that
we can be but also using new science and
new techniques so you know your your
three-year bad dream has probably
included you grabbing a test kit from
the post and putting it up in your nose
sending it back using intellectual
photos those sorts of things were not
available and not used by the public
prior to coving so we're better prepared
for future pandemics and we can use
those techniques for other infectious
disease and so I think there are
opportunities there in what we can do
going forward I'm going to try and again
if I may because you know you're being
very good science stuff in the questions
I'm going to wait for the public inquiry
and we don't want to be too
retrospective but you must have some
views on on the response and you know
we've got a lot of scrutiny on the Prime
Minister on the former prime minister
Boris Johnson as well is there do you
think that
so you would not expect me to comment on
individuals or politicians I don't think
that you'd expect that I think there are
lessons and many of them actually about
some of the learning and guidance for
somebody like me or a CMO whether it's
UK abroad have been published in a
document which have contributed to on
technical lessons which is probably our
area and I think there are things that
we can do firstly about preparedness a
getting testing set up that's not as
easy as it sounds so developing things
like panaceas which is a a sort of
technical way of saying we can have a
broad test and then we can hone it down
refine it when we have more detail I
think some of the areas where we've
learned is we've had very little
knowledge about environmental
transmission before and we need to do
that we need to factor into building
designs for example going forward as
well and one thing that worries me about
the impact of covid is public skepticism
around vaccines and the anti-vaxxist
movement online not just in related to
covert vaccines but also other really
important vaccines like chartered
vaccines for example is that something
that's concerned so there are a couple
of things here I think people have had a
bad time for the last three years and
actually we're almost seeing a little
bit of vaccine fatigue I mean I would
just like to highlight people
particularly the most vulnerable uh the
very elderly that that is the
life-saving intervention people sure
coded absolutely but we've also seen
over recent years not just recently a
drop off in primary childhood
vaccination and of course people have
forgotten the importance of that so
we've seen recently the emergence in so
cases for example of polio paralysis
from polio in Israel and the US and I
think these are strong reminders that we
need to boost our childhood vaccination
not remove them I mean polio it's one of
those things where you you think it's
almost been eradicated and then you have
that with other childhood illnesses as
well is there evidence that some of
these things are starting to resurface
here so the particular case we've got
now is because in some cases overseas
these live virus vaccines are used
that's not what we use routinely here
but then we can have odd cases being
coming into the country and if you don't
have a properly vaccinated population
then they can change and and actually
cause polio themselves so the real trick
here is just get your children
vaccinated for polio and they are
protected now you're a scientist or your
doctor and but you were suddenly thrust
into the public eye in a very extreme
way
um I think during the covid-19 pandemic
it became one of the most recognizable
people thanks to those daily press
conferences how was that
slightly strange not my natural place to
go and immediately project myself
forward on a number 10 Podium but lots
of learning and actually is a very
privileged responsible position as well
what I hope I was able to do alongside
politicians was speak directly to
members of the public who perhaps were
Keen to hid from scientism from
clinicians themselves and I know from
feedback I get that I have to meet
people and they say oh I think it feels
like we know you already you've been in
our sitting room there have been one of
two strange moments as well I've had a
chicken named after me for example
chicken a chicken and just this week
we've had a day with industry trying to
work on those Pathways to new vaccine
development and somebody who attended
our ukhsa put down offices settle my
daughter has a teddy bear named after
you these are these are not things I
would have anticipated when I entered
were you a bit worried that is there any
whatsapps from Matt Hancock my Thruster
on the front pages again uh well I I try
and exactly as I should as a civil
servant and always keep unbiased in what
I do very sensible advice thank you very
much for being the program thank you
I'm going to be there with Dr Jenny
Harris now it's time for something a
little bit different and an interview
that I found very difficult to do this
week but I think it's a subject that is
really important and I know impacts so
many people and so many families often
silently across the country now back in
the summer of 2020 the conservative MP
and Minister guy Opperman and his wife
Laura lost their newly born twin boys
now at the time he said that they
emerged from hospital shell shocked and
that coping with the grief was of course
very hard and there are more than half a
million births in the UK each year but
there are still many unknowns around
pregnancy childbirth and what can go
wrong guy has been trying to look at how
politicians and how Westminster can make
their experiences well if not easier
because they'll never be easier but he's
looking at some of the legislation
around that and a little earlier I spoke
to guy about his family's experience
so you have a little boy kitto I do how
old is he eight months and two days I've
got to get this right and the little
darling woke me at 4 21 am this morning
uh with a particularly Troublesome
snuffle and cough but we are fine what
sort of personality do you think uh
bubbly bouncy cheeky uh and always
smiling which is very sweet he's just
very optimistic he has a positivity
about life that is uh he wakes up
smiling and he basically lives his life
smiling which is wonderful to see his
glasses brimming over let alone half
full kitto there will always be your
third child yes
um the first child that you brought home
from yeah first take him child
um what what happened so flora and I did
IVF and struggle for very many uh years
to conceive and eventually had twins who
we managed to get just beyond 20 weeks
and then sadly in covid they came too
early basically and
uh one came and went very quickly and
the second child
uh lived for a very long and difficult
day but we were able to share that day
with them and we then
uh came to terms with the loss
but you you never regret the journey
you've been on if you know what I mean
and you never regret trying albeit like
many parents we weren't able to take our
children home how what happened when you
first found out found out your wife was
pregnant
um well obviously most of all if you've
been on an IVF Journey it's relief trust
me it's such a tough Journey
particularly obviously for the woman
but as a couple IVF is a miracle you
know none of our none of these people
who have had IVF would have been able to
conceive 30 years ago is the pregnancy
progressed and the baby's got bigger
well first of all you realize you're
pregnant then you realize you've got
twins
uh and then obviously you get to a a
state of uh fundamental happiness and
excitement and all the usual things that
parents get excited about
and Mild Terror as well yeah
and then
when did you find out that things were
so we had a scan and scan was going fine
and then a couple of days later
flow didn't feel well and had some
symptoms so we went into hospital she
went into Hospital of course because I
couldn't go
and uh as a consequence I was then rung
and told well actually
um things are not going at all well and
she'd begun giving birth way too early
and how old were they at that point
uh 21 going to 22 weeks so it was early
yes
um uh but this process that went on for
a little while and we lost one child and
then we kind of I mean we spent nearly a
week in hospital so yeah
um and you're trying to literally hang
on to the second child and lots of mums
lose one part of twins and
um
sadly that wasn't to be
how was that day you said it was a long
time uh it was a very long day and
you're so tired and you're so
overwrought and rung through and uh
and you are this also it's very tough
even in modern maternity units so all
around you mums and dads are giving
birth yes and you're tucked away in a
corner of a of a hospital
um trying to save a child or in reality
knowing because you've been given pretty
good advice
that is very very unlikely that your
child will either survive or that will
survive in a healthy form as well and
that if you're you can take said child
home there is a high degree of risk of
significant uh deformity or disability
by reason of coming so early you know
they just don't develop in the right way
they need to be in mum's tongue
basically
so uh
that's a tough gig because all around
you you can hear women giving birth
uh people being all excited
uh and
which makes it very difficult for the
parents and we've been through it but as
I say hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of other people have been through it as
well and you spent a lot of time talking
to your child as well
yes we had a very special
a couple of hours
where we communicated our hopes and
dreams and fears and aspirations
and sadnesses and also
um
uh and obviously held his hand and and
was with him and in circumstances where
we probably understood this may not
have a happy outcome
but
um the fair point to make is
I've yet to meet a parent who didn't
appreciate even if it is a short period
of time in neonatal intensive care
when the hospital tries to preserve the
life but also makes a delicate judgment
call
that
um some time for the parents as this
life
takes what is inevitably or in 99 times
out of 100 is an inevitable course is
utterly priceless
and there's a very difficult
conversation that the surgeon has to
have the consultant has to have with the
parents about what you want us to do and
do you want to try and resuscitate do
you want to try and
and that's not an easy one but I would
my lesson would be that day we spent uh
albeit long and difficult was priceless
yeah a day that you will always be yeah
of course you you you
um
you try your hardest to
encapsulate it remember it and savor it
because you realize it's probably not
going to be
um
long lasting and the bit that really
affects you is
um you know there are lots of mums and
dads who don't get another chance so you
know in the back of your mind this may
be your only time ever in a Maternity
Ward and you may only have a day and
that if that's what life brings you
that's what life brings you but
that's a lot to take
what did you call your your babies uh
Teddy and Rafe obviously this is such a
such a the worst thing that any parent
can go through the absolute worst thing
that any parent can go to through but I
guess having people like yourselves in
Parliament who go through these things
means that you can Advocate on behalf of
other people who've experienced it as
well which you have done so I had a
49-day sabbatical courtesy of his Truss
where I was on the back benches which
meant I could take part in uh
the back bench debate on uh this
particular issue and I was able to speak
on this and make the case on this and
have continued to advocate in a variety
of forms with Department of Health with
uh individual ministers Maria Caulfield
has been very helpful and also to try
and
um
uh advocating you know the letters MP
give you clout there's no doubt
whatsoever and whether it's myself or my
labor colleague Terry Perkins or others
who've been through this and there is an
all-party group on baby loss of which
cabinet members set it up and many
people one of the health ministers will
Quince is very active in that as well
there is a very strong Voice cross party
in Parliament
making the case for uh better outcomes
better services
and shouting the corner for those who
feel
uh utterly devoid of a voice the neonato
care bill is currently going through
Parliament something that you have
pushed for and supported and that's
about giving people proper time off to
after something like this yes um I I
think it's long overdue it has got
cross-party support
um it's in its last stages in Parliament
right now and bluntly it provides
support to an individual who's been
through this
um because you can't go back to work
straight away and you shouldn't be
fundamentally penalized in your employee
status by reason of a disastrous
maternal event that has affected you you
um are also pushing for lesser postcode
lottery in terms of care it is an honest
fact to say that in this wonderful
country it is not a universal nature of
care and you could be trying to give
birth or having a difficult pregnancy in
a particular part of the country and you
will not get as good a service
as you possibly will do in a specialist
Hospital in the center of London where
there are an awful lot of very
impressive professors and experienced
people do you think it's good enough for
maternity care at the minute I think
listen I think it is very good I know
that there's things like the oxygen
report and other reports bluntly we it
is very good in this country but it
could be a lot better you know um it's
2023 we could a we should have as close
to Universal approach secondly there
could be better guidance of how you deal
with uh births at 21 22 23 24 25 weeks
and a better understanding of how you
handle that and every child is different
every number is different but we could
be a lot better at that and I think they
are heading on that Journey
I can imagine that the
when you were pregnant with um when your
wife was pregnant with kiddo must have
been a stressful Journey for the obvious
reasons but when he arrived
healthy
that must have just been I can't almost
imagine what
um relief happiness and and the honest
truth is
um the degree of pain for those who
sadly are not able to conceive and take
home a child is enormous and they will
never get over that they just they you
just don't get over that
um your life goes on you get up you try
to go to work you try to have a positive
outlook on life
but uh you know there are too many
people out there who really struggle
with that so
uh it's mostly relief
and then obviously the underlying
happiness of and the Delight of 421a
wakeups I was saying obviously about him
being such a glass half full child yeah
he's a very very lovable young man who
it seems
worryingly optimistic about everything
in this rather tricky complex World
which is delightful and that's the most
the sweetest part of his character is
that
basically he seems just very chirpy
about everything
for sharing the story my pleasure
oh really powerful uh interview I'm sure
lots of people have been impacted by you
know what guy uh Opperman has talked
about so openly and say movingly and
will definitely support some of the work
that he's doing to try and change things
and make it
I mean I was going to say easy but it's
not easy obviously you can't make
something like that easier but to try
and change some of the legislation the
law and the help available to people and
parents who find themselves in the worst
possible situation
uh we can take a look ahead now uh in
the world of politics because we're
joined Now by two women who really know
their way around Westminster former
political advisor to the labor leader Ed
miliband Sonia soda and saurasha he was
a special advisor to the conservative
Home Secretary Saturday thanks both of
you for being on the program we've just
come off the back of a really moving
interview I know that you guys are both
very moved by it as well um and we were
sort of talking about how it is
important isn't to sort of humanize
politicians as well um
absolutely and I think it's it's that
thing it's kind of understanding that
our politicians are people who sometimes
go through horrible forms of grief as
well I think it's sometimes a useful
reminder given all the abuse they get
and you know the rightful scrutiny and
accountability which can be really
robust I think it's sometimes good to
remember their people too but also there
is such a terrible stigma still around
um miscarriage and it's a very kind of
particular painful form of grief I think
uh that that we we're starting to get
better as a society at talking about um
but I think there's probably still some
way to go yet yeah and I do think that
it's wonderful that guys talking about
it because it can't be easy at all but
you know that interview is going to
prompt conversations that interview
might sort of help somebody going
through a similar experience or help
other people understand whether those
experiences are so I think uh a really
great interview to do yeah I was really
happy that he was comfortable enough to
share his story and he did like you say
you could tell you tell by the way he
was in the interview how impacted he
clearly he still felt by it and also I
guess you know this is what Westminster
is best isn't it when you have people
who've gone through something like that
life changing you'll never get over it
as he says you know you just learn to
live with it rather than moving on from
there yeah and you can use your
experience to think hang on this like
why don't we have better leave for
example for people who've gone through
losing a child for a baby that should
happen you know and then actually use
their position to
to make a change no absolutely and quite
often on these sorts of issues it goes
across party as well which I think is a
useful reminder that you know despite
our politics which can be very toxic at
times there are some issues actually
which politicians from different values
and different political Traditions can
find Common Ground yeah yeah really
difficult subject to talk about I know
like you know we're all getting you know
it's difficult to watch and stuff so you
know
um we can talk a little bit more about
some of the other stories that we
covered on the program uh today the big
sort of announcement this morning was
about child sexual exploitation and to
try and get a basically a duty for
people to report if they've got any
concerns about particular children
because we've seen very vulnerable kids
in particular being targeted right
absolutely and it is really important so
we had the independent inquiry on child
sexual abuse which reported last year
after many many years of work I think
it's important to say look to all forms
of child sexual abuse in society so in
institutions grooming gangs but also in
the home and actually the sort of child
sexual abuse that goes on in the home it
is more common than we'd like to think
and it's really to boot all forms of
child sexual abuse are very taboo and
that gets in the way of it being
reported dealt with so much of it is
preventable but we sort of leave
children to suffer so I think it's
really good to see that the Home
Secretary is taking one of the
recommendations of that independent
inquiry last year my concern about this
announcement which is basically putting
a legal Duty on professionals who work
with children to report suspicions of
child sexual abuse
my concern about it is it puts a lot of
emphasis on the law as an instrument of
change and makes it sound like you know
this stuff isn't getting reported
because you know they're not legally
obliged to do it whereas actually if you
look at the research on this we know
that um you know it's very very taboo in
society which means that social workers
teachers Etc they can be quite reluctant
to identify it as a form of suspected
abuse because they know what it might
mean for a family in a school and I
guess I'd get it wrong then absolutely
there's not there's not enough training
around it for you know even social
workers get quite limited training on
child selection abuse what the signs to
watch for so the idea that you can just
fix it with a change in the law is I
think wrong and I think we've got so
much to do as a society to think about
well how do we keep you know how do
child professionals working with
children really keep their eyes and ears
peeled for some of the signs of child's
attributes because it is preventable you
know there are signs and children can be
taken out of those situations and
supported but too many children are
being left to come to suffer this awful
crime alone I do think that the
interesting thing here is that you can
put something down as a statue in a duty
but ultimately are you going to be able
to pull the system together in terms of
resourcing and you know these cultural
issues and training that you've just
mentioned Sonia about you need to get
what you want as the outcome so I mean
it's all it's all that stuff that we're
so used to in Westminster is that the
announcement is there you know that the
press release has gone out but actually
the follow-through is going to require
years of effort to make this actually
work yeah because it is so difficult
like you say and actually it's
interesting because you know I'm always
one of these people who I think if we're
talking about crimes that are
predominantly impacting women and girls
we should call that out and say it is
but I was quite pleased actually was
like actually there's a lot of boys that
yeah this impacts as well yeah and this
can be even more taboo and more
difficult yeah maybe not but but you
know it can be very difficult for this
yeah it's it's so to be it's so
different difficult for children to talk
about and raise their hands and say that
something's happening to them which is
why it's so important that every anyone
who works for children is aware of some
of the signs of it and feels comfortable
reporting it investigating it but we
definitely have a child protection
system at the moment where it is too
taboo yeah even amongst professionals
working with children so you know that's
that's why we're not able to do what we
should be doing for these children you
spoke a bit about
um in Westminster where you get the
press release out but it's the follow
through that matters and I just think
this really applies to some of the
policies around immigration as well
because with the interview today you
know I was trying to there's so much you
can answer Home Secretary about right so
you're kind of like thinking okay can do
this this police the announcement today
you've got immigration how do you
Whittle down and I could have made the
decision I guess not to focus too much
on Rwanda because it hasn't happened
right like no one's been sent there and
I do still have a bit of skepticism
about whether it is going to happen at
all because of the delays I don't know
what you sort of all sort of take us on
it well I think that there's so much
that is going on behind the scenes so as
a former home office special advisor you
know my sympathy
wave you know the difficulty of what you
need to do and the home secretary's
remit is so broad you know at any given
moment she's probably got sort of eight
crises going on that we're not even
aware of
um so you know I have some sympathy for
that what I think is interesting is that
you go big so you know like the prime
minister at the beginning of the year
has said we're going to deal with the
small boat stuff
um but then actually following through
with that then becomes difficult because
there are challenges that will come your
way that you probably didn't expect or
the ones that you did expect or you know
whatever you know tone that takes is
challenging uh so I do think that there
is a limit to what you can actually say
as kind of you know a running narrative
before you actually get to a point where
either something is fixed or it's really
obvious that it's not going to be and
she said be judged on the record and she
will be right yeah I mean she's really
holding herself hostage and Fortune
there because I mean I I agree with you
Sophie I think it's a completely
unworkable plan experts have literature
there are so many holes in it whether
it's kind of international law whether
it's the practicalities of where do you
detain people arriving in the UK I mean
there's detention is much much more
expensive than housing Asylum Seekers
we've got nowhere to do that you know
Rwanda the agreement with Rwanda is to
take you know what is effectively a
small handful of of you know the people
who are arriving on on small boat
um where are the where are the vests
going to go I mean it's just totally not
worked out and I can't help think that
if you're a home secretary that was
genuinely interested in addressing the
issue around an increasing volume of
Asylum claims but it's not the highest
it's ever been at the moment it is high
but it's not the highest it's ever been
lots of countries are seeing an increase
what you would do is focus on making the
Asylum system more Humane but also more
more robust so you would process lots of
these people are genuine Asylum Seekers
who are fleeing terrible conflict you
know from regions like Afghanistan where
Britain has been involved
um you know you would Pro you would look
at their claims you would assess them
fairly and quickly so people who've got
a logistics intimate claim to be here
can get a job can work for example can
start a new life but people who don't
have a legitimate claim you you Deport
and you deal with that at the moment
people who are genuine Asylum Seekers
people who suffered the most awful kinds
of torture and human rights abuses
attract in a system where it takes
months even years to process our
application that's not Humane it's not
fair to them and it's not fair in terms
of the system in terms you know there
are people here who could be deported
slightly In Contention though I think if
you're looking at from her perspective
and I'm playing devil's advocate here I
think the issue is how many of the
people that are coming over via this
route small boats route are genuine
Asylum Seekers now I don't I'm not
saying one way or another but I think
there has to be better numbers that are
published because the contention from
the home office is that actually you're
getting a lot of people who are coming
over the are economic migrants and I
think there should be much better
numbers yeah but if you look at the
countries from which they're coming
um you know the the top five countries
in terms of Asylum claims or countries
where we you know we know that there's a
very high success rate although Albania
is top where in terms of small boat
arrivals not in terms of the general
Albania I think is top of small boat
yeah yes exactly small boat but in
general
if you look at the overall Asylum system
the top five countries which include
small boats right but you're right
there's a different statistic
um but even with Albania so so there's a
lot of claims made that this is you know
these are the only way you can figure
this out is by process processing yeah
and getting better data there are
genuine because we have a massive human
trafficking problem across Europe that
actually affects women and girls women
being you know traffic for for sex work
essentially uh prostitution so um you
know it's it's I think it suits the Home
Secretary to be able to make claims
without evidence without the validity of
when it's our time it is such a hot
issue we could be talking about it all
morning thank you so much for uh coming
on the program today great to talk to
you I heard both on the show today
thanks
well that's it this week's at Sophie
Ridge on Sunday but don't go anywhere
because after the break we're going to
be running through each day's interviews
and chatting to our Deputy political
editor Sam coats thanks for joining us
this Sunday
[Music]
hello you're watching safety Ridge on
Sunday the take a chance to look back at
some of our interviews this morning on
the program discuss some of the issues
that we spoke about and what it means
the week ahead it feels like we had a
whole range of stuff on the program it
feels like reeling after actually
um the big interview of course with the
Home Secretary as well a brother and my
first time for a long time having her in
the studio to dissect some of those
controversial policies but also the chat
with guy Opperman the MP who spoke so
movingly about losing his twin boys is
stillborn
um and it's such a touching interview
and I just think it's really powerful
and something that will impact lots of
people if you missed it do get the
chance to watch that one back with
swella bravoid it was quite interesting
to try and work out the best way to
approach the interview there's so much
that we could have spoken about whether
it is crime whether it is antisocial
Behavior I did focus on immigration but
I try to do it in a slightly a different
way because of course they won't talk
about Rwanda they want to talk about
housing migrants on boats neither of
which have happened yet let's talk shall
we to our Deputy political editor some
codes to get his take on the interview
um Sam good to have you with us this
morning so the Home Secretary on the
program it was one of those interviews
where to be honest I wrote about three
different versions and then kind of
ripped them up and went with something
completely different at the end and what
did you make of the time the Home
Secretary this morning
foreign
well I suspect one of the reasons that
you did that Sophie is that it's not
routine that the Home Secretary is put
out on the kind of uh to sit in the
chair opposite you on a Sunday morning
we don't actually get very much of her
doing uh broadcast rounds like the one
she's out and about doing this morning
and there's a very clear it's very
obvious reason for that which is when it
comes to government policy her and
Richie soon like it's just a little bit
further apart from one another uh than
perhaps number 10 is entirely
comfortable with so they look at these
moments with nervousness they know that
it could be a moment where divisions uh
or certainly differences and emphasis
between uh the Home Secretary and the
Prime Minister uh can can come through
which is why I think it's quite
interesting uh the way that essentially
they have decided they decided to put
quite a big and important announcement
the Forefront of the home secretaries uh
uh media around this morning with this
uh announcement about the mandatory Duty
for people involved working with
children to report if there are any
signs of child sexual exploitation it's
a very very big moment and it's one that
I think will be broadly speaking
welcomed by uh professionals it is
Sophie the combination of seven years
work it was 2018 when a conservative
government actually rejected the plan
that now this government has decided to
press ahead with because if you do make
it a criminal offense for people that
work with children not to report uh
signs of sexual abuse there were fears
that that might overwhelm the system
that there simply wasn't the resource to
investigate every single claim made
professionals nervous that the real
repercussions for them if they didn't
point out absolutely everything but the
government have decided to uh change the
policy in favor of this in uh quite a
big moment but I thought it was
fascinating to listen how soella
Braverman decided to sell this policy on
your show this morning
vulnerable White English girls
um sometimes in care sometimes who are
in challenging circumstances being
pursued and raped and drugged and harmed
by gangs of British Pakistani men who've
worked in child abuse Rings or networks
we've seen institutions and state
agencies whether it's social workers
teachers the police uh turn a blind eye
to these to these signs of abuse out of
political correctness out of fear of
being called racist out of fear of being
called bigoted
yeah you taught there about how she
decided to sell the policy and I think
you're right that it's going to be
something that will be welcomed the
actual ideas behind the policy and that
something is finally hopefully being
done after a consultation even if that
happens
um but she's leaning into the racial
aspect of it right she's talking about
British Pakistani men and she's talking
about people not reporting because of
political correctness
that's right and and what solo
Brotherman is doing there is referring
to some of the appalling stories that we
got um in the last decade often reported
in the times actually by Andrew Norfolk
about what happened in Northern towns uh
with uh Pakistani gangs but that is only
the tip of the iceberg and and it's
worth reminding viewers that you know
the inquiry that's led to this change is
the inquiry into the Jimmy Savile Affair
that's the uh body of work after that
Scandal the BBC presenter uh who uh
later turned out to uh have committed
horrific uh uh acts of uh abuse uh and
pedophilia uh it is the inquiry into how
that happened I think that's the main
reason that has nudged the government
into doing that and that had nothing to
do with Northern gangs uh so I think
there are a variety of different uh
triggers for the change in the
legislation but the Home Secretary
choosing uh to pick one as it were type
of case to publicize it Lisa nandy the
shadow leveling up secretary actually
pointing out that there are other groups
that are vulnerable in indeed it's not
just young girls it is uh also some uh
boys as well I mean there was a major
report about five years ago into the
state of uh sexual abuse of minors and
it is just incredible when you read
through the sheer amount of depraved
behavior that is that is going on below
the surface in this country it is a real
Scourge and a real problem affecting far
more uh I think than is uh is is often
recognized and often talked about and
and that's the thing I think that
everybody wants to uh tackle and sort
out uh as quickly as possible that's
absolutely right absolutely right
um let's talk about immigration shall we
because of course that was also a big
part of the interview with Zoella
Braverman there's been a lot of
headlines about Rwanda an awful lot of
headlines about a policy that hasn't
actually born any fruit yet no one has
actually been deported to Rwanda no
matter your feelings on whether it is
the wrong or the right policy so I was
kind of keen to not just focus on that
which I think a territory perhaps the
Home Secretary is comfortable talking
about whether or not you agree with her
or not but also to look about the wider
immigration picture let's have a little
lesson
listen I uh we are making very steady
progress will they take off by this I'm
not going to give a deadline as to when
flights will take off uh we have to be
realistic okay we've had a very strong
victory in the high court at the end of
last year on Rwanda we've now introduced
legislation we want to move as quickly
as possible to relocate people from the
UK to Rwanda
no deadline Sam
no and they can't do that because they
don't know when the legislation that
underpins a lot of this is going to get
through the houses of Parliament so in
the last month uh ministers the Home
Secretary introduced the immigration
bill that's winding its way through
Parliament but it's going to hit the
House of Lords and when it hits the
House of Lords it's gonna have more
amendments than the Christmas tree uh
strung up all over it and that will slow
down its passage it is not clear that
the legislation that makes their
immigration policy possible will be on
the statute books this year and then
separately you were referring to Rwanda
now the issue there is that although the
government scored a victory in the high
court over uh uh the legality of the
Rwanda policy last year the high court
also said that there's needs to be a
special care and attention on every
single individual case it's not clear
that domestically you're going to get uh
cases individuals being waved through to
be returned and there is another
separate question about how the European
Court of Human Rights the Strasbourg
Court what happens if that Court decides
that once again for a second time that
the flights can't take off last time uh
this government uh the uh the Tory
government decided that it had to obey
the ruling from from Strasbourg I'm
getting mixed signals about whether or
not they would just ignore such a
direction or whether the strazball court
wouldn't dare uh repeat that ruling a
second time or whether they would just
uh ignore it all together so there's a
lot of uncertainty I I think some in
government think that for instance the
sort of Gary lineker Rao the attack by a
a well-known media personality of the
government's uh immigration plan uh
actually the net win for Rich you see
like in the sense that uh he was quite
proud of the way and quite firm in the
way that he defended the policy uh in
quite neutral terms I think southern
governments saw that actually is
beneficial because it gave the Prime
Minister a big platform to set out their
plans but it has to be be uh you just
come back to two points Sophie first of
all none of this has actually happened
and secondly actually if you look at the
polling laborer ahead of the Tories on
immigration I suspect because their
focus too on delivery and and that
really hasn't begun yet yeah I thought
that's really interesting I saw some of
that polling six points ahead I think it
was on immigration labor which it does
feel quite unusual if you look at it
what's happened over uh recent uh years
uh Sam thanks for analysis are we going
to have more from Sam but uh before we
do just want to play this quick clip
from the Home Secretary Brotherman
because people are heading to France
this weekend from Dover have really
experienced those Bad Keys Lots having
to wait overnight some delays are more
than 16 hours and earlier asked the Home
Secretary whether following brexit this
could be a new normal
no I don't think that's fair to say this
has been uh you know an adverse effect
of brexit I think we've seen we've had
many years now since leaving the
European Union and there's been on the
whole very good uh operations and
processes the order but what I would say
is that acute times when there is a lot
of pressure uh crossing the channel
whether that's uh on the the tunnel or
the ferries then I think that there's
always going to be a backup and I just
urge everybody to be a bit patient while
the ferry companies work their way
through the backlog
and on those severe delays and Dave I
also asked a labor Shadow leveling up
secretary Lisa nandi if it was brexit
there was effectively to blame
we haven't had a government that has
planned for what was going to happen
post-brexit there are clearly a range of
factors that have gone into the delays
here and we've seen them before but um
the government has known for a very long
time that they needed to make sure that
there were resources in place to deal
with additional paperwork checks the
point is not whether we left the
European Union or not the point was that
we left with a government that made big
promises and once again didn't deliver
well let's talk to our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates um what do you make of
the two that we no one really wanted to
say it was because of brexit directly
did they
now I mean you I I mean you just sort of
sigh at both of those answers later on
in the interview the Home Secretary said
that uh she saw her job as essentially a
truth teller well the reason one of the
big reasons that there are delays at the
Port of Dover is that there is
additional paperwork for people to get
into the European Union it is a factor
it just is as the head of the port of
Dover uh has been saying and it and it
feels odd to deny it Point Blank you can
do things about it as uh the government
there must be uh ways that uh you can
put in more border posts that you can
try and ease some of those delays but
you just uh just denying Point Blank I
don't think necessarily uh that brexit
has anything to do with it it
necessarily will fill people with the
confidence that this issue is going to
be solved and then you've got labor that
sort of wants to avoid having a row
about the principles of brexit as ever
as with every single policy issue uh
labor front benches decline to deal with
the substance and instead instead blame
the government for incompetence whether
it's immigration whether it's brexit
there's the same pattern I wonder how
well it goes down with the public never
engaging on the big issue of the day but
just saying the government hasn't shown
that it can't manage things properly
it's a Playbook that I wonder uh whether
or not um wears the public down in the
weeks and months to come yeah it's
interesting and you've definitely called
it out before as well
Sam I'm interested to get your overview
because you speak about it a little bit
in the interview when when we were
chatting earlier and it does feel like
solar problem is leans in doesn't she to
these culture War issues you know
whether it is Rwanda she leans into it
whether it is the child sexual abuse
she's talking about political
correctness there she's saying that
she's a truth teller that she doesn't
mind standing up to the BBC or Gary
lineker
do you think that she's an asset to the
conservative party when it comes to
elections or do you think that actually
she's putting off too many voters
um I don't know I mean I think that that
really is a judgment for for voters but
I I would just as ever urge in politics
you could never quite be cynical enough
um yes she talks a good game she talks a
game that will appeal to uh selectra a
part of the conservative party in a part
of the country uh no doubt but I I think
the interesting question with Zoella
bravaman is whether the talk whether the
rhetoric lives up to the reality so she
is in a government that's done a
compromise deal over brexit of the sort
that frankly I didn't think that uh she
would be particularly happy about
wearing she's done a a compromise deal
over immigration and she wants to leave
the European uh convention on human
rights but this plan doesn't necessarily
deliver that I do wonder whether or not
the tough talk and the reality are close
enough for her liking yeah she did say
that she judged me on my record and I
think we will get the opportunity to do
that when those figures come through
thanks very much Sam that is it from
suffrage on Sunday the take this morning
do check out the podcast around
lunchtime
[Music]